hello and welcome to insight Germany my
guest today is one of the research group
leaders of experimental neurosurgery and
the world-famous Shaggy T University
Hospital here in Berlin
Anna Louisa Pena is originally from
Mexico and came here to Germany at the
turn of the millennium first to the
lovely medieval city of Regensburg in
Bavaria and since 2006
she's been here in rough-and-ready
Berlin
welcome to the show when you arrived in
Germany you were in as I just said this
beautiful city of Regensburg which we're
going to visit later in the show I mean
did you did you think everything in
Germany was like a medieval movie set
yes actually it was strange that I began
to work in this small city it was just
by chance I was in Montreal before and I
was looking for a job and one of my
colleagues told me say why don't you
just look at very good job here also
ingredients pork they are opening many
opportunities for research group leaders
and I have the fortune to start there
wonderful I I was amazed to see this
wonderful city and the buildings and
everything it was like like a fairy tale
basically so then it was fantastic to
live there and also the work was
incredible and I was very very happy
there my boss was supporting me all
hundred-percent and so why did why did
you come to as I said rough-and-ready
but is not quite as originally I have to
say I love Berlin I love Regensburg but
I am completely for I completely fall in
love with Berlin and I came because I
got married I told him with the British
man
and this British man was already living
here in Berlin that's why I came here
and of course I was but we were getting
married but I was still in Regan's war
and then I was looking for a similar job
that I had in dragans were here and I
have the incredible fortune to be in the
charity so then I started with the right
food as we say in Mexico I started here
with a new life and with wonderful work
definitely now tell us about your work
because when I I heard you were coming
to the show it was sort of a
neuroscientist it's quite daunting to me
I know about science so if you can for
me and in layman's terms for our
audience tell us what is neuroscience
and especially experimental neurosurgery
okay well neuroscience is the study of
the central nervous system and the
nervous system in general so our brain
and and the central nervous system and
the nervous system in general is this
system that allow us to to see and to
behave and to and to dream and to to do
everything that has to be between
outside and inside how to learn and
everything and for me
in experimental neurosurgery we have as
neurosurgeons normally treat people with
surgery in the brain for example to take
tumors but also we do a lot of research
on trauma patients and on stroke
patients and all these patients
unfortunately they they they have these
diseases and we want to help them to to
create therapies that are not so
aggressive and that can help them to
recover and and this is basically what
we are doing in at least in experimental
neurosurgery and neurology experimental
neurology and how much do you know in
that I I heard from a neurologist that
we know about 20% of what's going on in
the brain and 80% we really
it's just we really don't know yes is
that true yes yes we are in diapers as
we could say we it's a guess work in
some way I mean we know many parts of
what what are they the parts of the
brain yeah and how they connect and in
etcetera but the still we don't know
what is this that makes for example a
degenerative disease like Alzheimer
disease that you you lose your memory
first of all or Parkinson disease where
you lose neurons that makes you begin to
tremble yeah without any control and all
these degenerative diseases are
increasing and increase with age and and
we are very interested to know in this
in this in decide and we are trying
there are millions of people trying to
go into research on the and that so
neuroscience is about the study of the
normal nervous system but also the
diseased nervous it's a big subject
Alzheimer's and dementia things we talk
about now a little more I do want to
know that how do you study the human
brain in that you can't work with live
ones or can you I mean I yes well there
are different levels you can you can
work at the molecular level and for
example we have the opportunity to have
the patients there and we have for
example blood samples or urine samples
and we can know some for example some
markers of disease in the blood or the
in the urine of these persons but also
we can do life imaging how is the the
brain is working for example and we can
we have now wonderful machines like
magnetic resonance and functional
magnetic resonance also and PET scan
that is more positron emission
tomography and all these make us first
not to invade the patient but also to
seek what what is happening inside the
brain meanwhile they are doing certain
activities for example and if these
activities are there similar to the
normal
or they are of a deceased person how how
they change how is the brain changing
whenever whenever there is a disease
okay now we should explain where my
guest works so there's a Museum of
medical history within the grounds of
the world-famous chef ET hospital and we
went there to find out more about this
renowned institution and before we go on
we've got this fascinating book you can
see now from the Sheraton Museum to give
away it is in German but they've sent as
an English supplement here to go with it
it's all about medical history down the
ages so write to us at insight at dwae
and you could be the lucky one to come
out of the Hat please include your
postal address of course what's so
special for you about the charity
working there
well incredible because you know I mean
when I started when I was very very
young
when I was around 11 years old I was
reading a book that this is about the
history of of microbes it's a hunting
hunting micros one of the names when you
were 11 you live in years old and I was
fascinated I was always fascinated by
this kind of books and my father gave me
this book and he I was reading about all
the people Robert Koch and they were
discovering all these diseases Pasteur
co-heir leash and then suddenly I am
here in 2006 in front of the first
building I was working in it was Paul
early building I was like oh my god what
is this and like three or four days
later there was a big talk in in in one
of the big buildings in the chart a with
and the name is there is a museum
because Robert Koch was working there so
then he said fantastic and say oh my god
what is this so
for me working in a place where there
are so many Nobel Prize winners seven in
all ya know and so you can imagine I was
so fortunate to be here and my
colleagues are fantastic I I have
wonderful opportunity to have the best
of the best students all over the world
know that I have students from from
America from the United States from
Mexico from from Turkey from China from
every everybody comes here to study and
of course I feel really fortunate so
then what I like from charity everything
yeah we talk there about the students
how do they differ do they they're very
different from different countries
around them oh definitely they approach
to science so you you have a certain
formality for science and I am
passionate about my work about about
science and I like that my students are
also passionate about that but whenever
we address a question I see that were
different characteristics like where is
our origin original country then this
makes a different point of view how how
how you see a question and how you want
to address this question to do
experiments and this is very enriching
especially when we are talking it's very
interesting because I will tell you for
example one day we were in the
microscope I I I'm always checking a
microscope and astrologist
so then microscopes for me are the basic
instrument and I was with a German study
a German student and a Turkish student
and we were looking at some labeled
cells and they look like black
background and some lights and we are
used to see these cells label but when
one of my German student was saying oh
yes this is this is the label sale that
is blah blah blah no so very scientific
and and the other students say oh yes it
looks like a starry night here
it was so nice because then we began to
laugh because this enriched a lot yeah
our were mu of science and our view of
how science can be done yeah but you
that's interesting but you did say
before we talked about the Nobel Prize
winners I I looked up on this that
Germany's 118 Nobel Prizes 68 of those
are for Natural Sciences or medicine
you mentioned car max planck einstein
roentgen who invented the x-ray it goes
on and on why I mean our Germans or is
Germany particularly good at science and
medical things or scientifically I think
III have the impression that physics
chemistry and biology or medicine is one
of the very basic things here like it's
very very strong and I don't know it's I
think it's a it's this combination of
how the German mentality is I think is
it's very organized it's very go to the
point very like into we have to arrive
to a decision and we have to arrive to
to to a goal i I don't want to say that
the rest of the world is not like this
because all scientists we in some way we
share this no but maybe maybe something
to be with how the mentality was
developed here for science I don't know
but I feel like we've been praising them
a lot and praising the share it a and
the facilities and all the medical side
of things we all know the health system
here is wonderful but what are they not
good at then in the in the medical side
so maybe maybe for me as a patient
sometime I have been not so many times
things Allah Lord that I am NOT so so so
always a disease or something but I am
NOT a patient but but I have the
impression that sometimes the personal
part is not there I think in general
medical doctors all over the
they they lose a little well they have
to be a little bit cold because of
course it's not possible to do yes
approach you know they have to stay cool
let's say in order to approach the
problem but I have the impression that
for example in Mexico or Latin America
people doctors are a little bit more
personal and then just to touch your
hand can make a difference the
touchy-feely some don't you feeling and
and that I am here for to support you
something like this here they are more
formal and as a way we are going to do
these diseases I think is changing
because also in neuroscience is the
discoveries that that also this personal
touch can help a lot it's like like
there are there is a lot of chemistry
changing whenever you treat a person in
a very very tender way or when you are a
little bit more distant so then it's
interesting perhaps we'll touch on that
again I want to go back though to to
Mexico to there's a very cute photo so
if I may say so had just wonder were you
thinking you said just a bit ago you
were reading a book on microbes at the
age of eleven how old are you there I
was three years old and the person that
he's holding my hand is my father that
he was always I have to say that since
then he was always giving me books so
he's my relationship with him he was
very very much about books and how to
learn things and for me was very
important
his influence on my career also and when
did it really start your fascination
then with medicine I mean at 3 you can't
really remember we can't remember much
to wear for camera you can remember
things yes but of course is more
difficult with age of course there but
but I think my fascination I think since
I was like around 5 years old my father
gave me a small toy that was for me
fascinating and this was a microscope I
was more microscope my toys that's a toy
and
I began to see absolutely everything I
was cutting absolutely everything leaves
and everything and insects and
everything and I was just fascinated by
that I was five years old and and then I
asked for another microscope and he was
a little bit bigger it was still a toy
but it was like and my father saw that I
just wanted to see through the
microscope and that's why I think he
also gave me this wonderful wonderful
book that he was from public office
Micro contours is the name should share
a picture of your father
oh yes there's another one yes so then
in the central part my parents
yes he's standing up and my mother is
there they just got married at that time
and then the family also my grandparents
and my grandmother in the in this right
side from the part of my mother and my
grandparents from parents of saying you
know three generations yes and any
connection to the generations because
there is one of my cousins that are very
very you the only doctor oh no there I
think we have in the family around five
or six doctors in physics or in biology
or in chemistry yes that there are some
around and just I should say you're not
a a medical doctor are you cuz in in the
English language anyway when we say
doctor we immediately think of that chap
you go and see to about your throat or
whatever but you're a doctor of I am a
doctor in neuroscience neuroscience so
originally I studied what is biomedical
research was a new career in Mexico and
then after that I did my master's in
neuroscience and then I did my PhD in
neuroscience mm-hmm that was back in
Mexico okay let's have a look at my
guest life here in Berlin ah insight
reporter Nora's cinema Diallo spent a
day with her recently
I lead a neuroscience research group
this work involves developing ideas and
proposing questions about how the brain
works in particular I am interested in a
specific protein important for
neuroprotection after injury and how
this
protein contributes to neural plasticity
together with my students we design
experiments that allow us to investigate
this relationship
I am the doctoral and master's thesis
advisor of my students I love science I
love my work and I hope my students
develop this same passion for science
and in particular for neuroscience here
we are in one of the oldest buildings of
the chart a may be the oldest two or
three hundred years old it is
fascinating to see all this old
furniture most is at least fifty years
old this part of the building will be
renovated soon the rooms used to house
an endocrinology workgroup now it
belongs to the experimental neurosurgery
the department in which I have the very
good fortune to work there is some much
history in these walls dancing is very
important to me it is on the one hand a
way of getting some exercise but also
one of my big passions I am now getting
interested in how dancing in particular
tangle can help patients with
Parkinson's disease actually everything
that involves learning like dancing
music language is very beneficial in
developing the plasticity of the nervous
system learning new things in particular
dancing increases the brain's capacity
to recover from injury or cope with
illness meditation has helped me to
reduce the high stress levels created by
work and everyday life the time and form
of meditation can even contribute to our
wellness and a state of happiness it is
one of my aims in my work to bring
meditation into neuroscience
meditation could have beneficial effects
on stress and even depression
and my guest is Ana Luiza Pena from the
charity Hospital and neuro scientists
there I must ask you about dance
straightaway and Parkinson's disease
tell us a little bit more how can it
help people with Parkinson's disease
well first of all probably I have to
tell you what is about brain plasticity
that this is exactly my next question so
and then I can tell you why it's
important this is dancing so plasticity
the brain is adaptable so it adapts to
everything for example when you are
learning you are adapting your brain to
different different inputs yeah from all
the atmosphere that you have and only
but also is adaptable whenever you have
an accident for example so then this
meaning like the adaptability or
plasticity of the brain is quite quite
big now one of the things is that we
want to learn to to help the the brain
for this plasticity because some
plasticity has a limit whenever you have
an accident and if the accident is too -
too bad then the brain has a limit and
we want as researchers to help it - to
improve faster and to recover faster and
it has been done by many other
researchers and now I'm very interested
in that that for example dancing
learning and another language or
learning to cook or learning - - neato
anything that you learn doesn't matter
how old you are this is very important
because it's very very official for for
the brain to improve the plasticity so
then you have like a level of plasticity
that is higher if you have that then
your brain is a little bit more
protective for diseases what happened
with Parkinson is that there are many
cells that are dying that are
dopaminergic cells I will not go into
that but this
cells that have a particular problem
then they make if you lose these cells
that the person's begin to have
trembling trembling and they cannot move
and then and apparently whenever you
dance whenever you dance tango in
particular your balance has to be very
good because you have to balance to the
person with the person that you are in
front dancing and you have to be
connected you are first connected by by
this embrace yeah but also is you have
to be coordinated with the music so all
these comes together and helps the brain
to learn how to balance also and how to
be a little bit more closer to the other
person that is in front of you and to
coordinate your brain with the music and
what you have to do this this helps it
has been observed that Parkinson disease
patients have a lot of problems with
balancing and this training for tango
particularly for the balance of the
tango that normal tango training it
helps a lot for this patient that's sort
of a physical thing down so what about
the psychological thing I know in the
film there you do yoga you meditate
you're a scientist inside you're
different to a lot of Sciences in my
opinion scientists tend to see
everything in black and white but you
seem to have a very spiritual side oh
yes in fact I I think when you begin to
do meditation you begin to go into
different levels also and you begin to
understand that this is about energy and
and how you can improve this energy in
order to help us or your brain I mean
for me was it's not only the stress but
I think whenever even you are sad
because there are many parts of the law
of life of everybody that that is sad
and this sadness can go away whenever
you are doing meditation and to to
relieve a lot of pain that you you have
and this makes me feel that that it's
not all about this black and white and I
think it's very difficult for many
scientists to see that but I think I'm
not the only one spiritual is spiritual
but also scientific because my my
curiosity about how this meditation is
making me change my stress and how is
making me fourth somehow when I'm sad or
when I have a problem or something
it makes me easier and this will help
that say the central nerve my my brain
to to also relieve and to be more
plastic this is also connected with this
caring and sharing and then exactly yes
certainly they may not be the best at it
in Germany but they're certainly
researching it oh definitely definitely
yes very briefly um I read something the
other day I wonder if you can comment on
this working with false limbs people who
have false limbs from war victims or
whatever and that they now have as it's
starting that they can control these
limbs by thought process from the brain
is this really or definitely definitely
actually actually there is there are
some researchers already doing a
connection between biomechanics like
like to have false limb limbs and
instead of being just something that to
support a person you can really move
them by thinking by thinking it's
fantastic actually I would tell you that
there are some researchers here in
Berlin that they are doing for example
how you can move a car just by thinking
it's fascinating and this has to be with
networks and networks my our brains are
made like networks also so then this is
very very very interesting artificial
intelligence basically I mean one more
of the I had I fell over a couple of
years ago and had stitches in my face
and I wanted to know about the
connection with anesthesia as well
because that's something that's sort of
booming in the scientific field like
neuroscience
when I had stitches in my face I could
feel them stitching but it didn't hurt
I'm a man I'm a coward
so the anesthetics normally so you have
different receptors to different for
example to heat and to pressure and to
pain you have the receptors that could
feel the pressure yes but not exactly
and you can feel even they and then it's
all about anesthetics is about pain how
you can reduce the pain yes enough
science let's go back well go back to
your dad you say so much about your dad
here he was very special to you oh
definitely
this is actually the person that
influences me more and every day I would
say yeah and in my personal life and in
my new mama I believe was coasters the
German yes because she was my her
sisters by her sisters yes she has
plenty of sisters and and and she she
was very strict so it was a contrast I
have a wonderful contrast with my
parents because my mother was absolutely
super organized super like six o'clock
in the morning doing yoga and doing this
and that and that and my father was a
little bit more relaxed but also super
worker and very punctual everything but
he was a little bit more relaxed he was
just enjoying more life no and my my
aunts used to say on say all she it's
just like a German
she's so extreme he came to Germany she
came to Germany yes yes unfortunately
not my mother but my father came to
Germany because this isn't from Germany
no to do with why he came yes yes so he
came here to Germany and to many
different capitals like London also on
other other capital main capitals cities
in
in the world and he was visiting because
he was one of the first if not the first
time I could say it's the first traffic
engineer in Mexico so he dedicated
himself to do to see how to control the
traffic lights basically so what he did
is that he came here and at some point
this is a control in the in the photo is
a control for for traffic lights and he
learned here how to semi computerize
these controls that were mechanical
before so people like traffic police
they were coming and they were turning
off and on and then suddenly they began
to be this is in the 60s so then the
computerization was not really
interested he wasn't bringing this to
Germany yes no he was from Germany to
Mexico so then they were yes gonna say
the Germans are normally he was
fascinated by Germans because of this
exactly because of the computerization
of traffic lights and yes this is
exactly what he brought from Germany he
loved German people by the way and when
he was here in Berlin and in Munich as
you do now I mentioned at the start of
the show the city of Regensburg which is
where my guests first worked and when
she arrived in Germany it really is a
classic picture postcard town
the spires of regensburg cathedral rise
105 meters above the city
so Peters is the central landmark and ov
areas only Gothic cathedral
another symbol of Regensburg is the 300
meter long stone bridge an architectural
masterpiece from the Middle Ages
the bridge builder is himself
immortalized here in a stone carving
known as the bridge man remains of the
Porta Pretoria
the main city gate testified to Oregons
Berg's time as a Roman legion camp in
the second century AD Regensburg is one
of the oldest cities in Germany in 2006
the entire old town was declared a
UNESCO World Heritage Site and tourists
have since come in their Millions I was
spending the night or just visiting for
the day the old buildings in the history
interest me the most the incomparable
atmosphere this is a medieval city like
no other in Germany we usually just see
half timber houses but here there are
stone buildings several stories high so
on one hand there's the architectural
aspect and I also find the atmosphere
with young people sitting outside almost
like Italy thousands it's possibly a
target another attraction and waggons
Berg is sent in our own palace the
ancestral home of the princely turn and
taxes family
the large ballroom and Princess Teresa's
chamber where that Swan bed are included
in the part of the palace open to
visitors
scholars and researchers have access to
the court library its historical
inventory comprises some 100,000 books
just a few minutes walk from the palace
there's another interesting sight Our
Lady of the old chapel thought to be the
oldest church in Bavaria
after many alterations in the 18th
century the old chapel was rebuilt in
the Bavarian Rococo style we see today
political center trading hub and World
Heritage Site Regensburg has a rich
legacy from many eras
now looking at that how did you ever get
any work done it was so difficult
because he is so beautiful and every
single corner you can discover something
new and it's incredible because you can
see if you go walking you just see
completely different city when you do
like this is a completely different city
because you see all these towers and
fantastic the buildings and it was I
believe different in in another way too
with working because you're still in a
relatively male-dominated profession was
it very different Regensburg and berlin
yes yes I think came a barrier that
Regan symbol ayah and I think they are a
little bit more matured and I'm not sure
a macho macho yes there's more macho
style and more dominated by by by men
and it's a quite difficult situation for
me was a shock because I was in the
States and also in Canada and even
Mexico and I saw more women working
there as scientists then when I was in
in in the in the Faculty of Medicine and
in the clinic University clinic in
Regan's Board I was treated wonderful by
my boss but I saw that the other bosses
or all the people or other colleagues
were kind of not so gentle and is that
different now in Berlin I think so yes
when I arrived it was a contrast because
the many of my colleagues were women in
the same positions that I have so then
it was very very it was comfort for me
because then I see that that means more
equivalent treated equivalent to two men
so yes it changed but I think it's
changing a lot also in in the South
let's say yes but this is a core it was
a contrast at that time now we have a
questionnaire which we've already you
talked about Regensburg in your
questionnaire be
which is one thing you also said your
favorite place is Mexico Platte but yes
here in Berlin there is a place called
Mexico flats and I actually dug out a
picture not of yours I dug out this
picture because just to show the
audience this is the Mexico plots
railway station yes yes it was
apparently one of the first electrical
railway stations here in Germany and in
lifting Berlin and they they built these
complete flats or square yeah as with
this style is very new boys so all the
buildings around it and I have the
fortune to live in one of these
buildings is fantastic because this is
like it's like a dream and it's Mexico
plates so I Mexican living in Mexico
like this yeah quite one of the most
beautiful railway stations you've ever
seen looking at the rest of the the
questionnaire you put is the coolest
living German your professor professor
Dean Michael
he is my ability inventor so ability
ssin is a different degree after you do
your PhD in order to be here in Germany
a professor so it's equivalent to be a
full professor and so in order to be a
full professor you have to pass this
kind of and other tests you have to do a
simulation actually if I may interrupt
you you're being very modest because I
looked up habilitation and habilitation
is the highest academic qualification a
scholar can achieve
so my advice for ability ssin is this
professor denial and he has he's a
medical doctor but he's also a PhD and
he is a wonderful character he I have
the fortune to be his well he isn't yet
my advisor and he guides me which are
the the steps that I have to follow to
be successful in my ability and he's a
world-famous researcher and and on top
is a wonderful guy really yeah favorite
German song do you remember what you put
down this might remind you can we hear
it Jamin anthem yeah one of my favorites
yes yes I just love it I don't know
anything
did you yeah actually a very good take
this one of the nicest piece of music
because you've written by Heidi and I
believe I read does this associate
you're about to become a German yes yes
I'm inspecting in some months I don't
know months or days or weeks to to have
my German passport I hope and yeah I'm
very happy because this is like in my
heart I feel that I am German I I would
like to would you give up your Mexican
of course not like would never do sorry
I is your heart divided yes my heart is
divided but mixed I and I think it's not
a difficult decision you can love two
persons or you can love two
nationalities a lot and in my case is
definitely German nationality and and
Mexican I am very proud of being part of
here in Germany to be here in Germany
but I am also my Mexican part is there I
mean these are my roots yeah I am
continue to be that and just to finish
on really you put here under something
the Germans do extremely well their love
of nature their organizational skills I
think we know
and the profundity of their relationship
oh yes yes yes my very very good friends
I always I always do this connection
with cocoanuts how is a German like a
coconut because sometimes they are very
hard to go into yeah but once you are
inside you have this sweetness of this
German friendship once you are there you
are there forever yeah and it's so sweet
and it's so wonderful so I love Germans
I think that that is a beautiful way to
end the Germans are like coconut thank
you very much thank you thank you all
for watching remember that one you heard
it first here the Germans are like
coconuts hard on the outside soft on the
inside and very sweet yes very sweet
join us for another program next week at
the same time have another fascinating
guest good bye for now
bye bye